Hi, mystery recapped here. Today I'm
going to explain the action horror film
called It Came From The Desert .
Spoilers ahead. Watch out and take care
The movie begins with what seems like a ball
of fire falling from the sky and crashing
into the desert in New Mexico leaving
behind a humongous hole on the ground.
The movie then fasts forward to 67 years later.
Alarms are going off inside a hidden facility
in the same desert. Armed men are running in fear
looking for a safe exit while battling what seems
like huge ants, bigger in size than all humans.
Unfortunately, one by one all of the men fall
and none of them make it out alive.
The movie then cuts to two cowboys,
Jorge and his pal driving in their Nissan truck
in the desert. They stop at the edge of a chasm
and notice a tunnel at the bottom. They bring out
their concrete trolley and venture into the tunnel
to fetch any scrap copper they could find. The
tunnel leads to a desolate facility called the
Chicane industries. As Jorge inspects the ground
for metal, he is suddenly attacked by giant ants,
sending his partner running back to the
truck in fear. However, before he could
reach the vehicle, the ant gets to him.
The movie then cuts to a guy named Brian
watching a movie called the Eradicator
on his TV in his garage. In the TV film,
a blonde girl is being attacked by a hideous
monster and calls out for John “Eradicator” Cage,
the male protagonist for help. The Eradicator
then shows up in a fancy sports bike.
He sprays the green monster with bullets and
rescues the girl like in any cheesy hollywood
movie. The girl then throws herself over the hero
and he asks her to give her some “sugar”. The two
make out as Brian vicariously lives through the
movie imagining himself as the “Eradicator”.
Brian is a nerdy university student who works
part-time as a mechanic and repairs racing
bikes. Brian’s cool, racer best friend Lukas then
shows up and asks him to hurry up for a party.
Brian and Lukas are excited for the party as
the Eradicator himself is gracing the event
and awarding Lukas his medal for winning
his university’s extreme sports bike race.
As they load Lukas’s sports bike on their pick
up truck, a missing people’s poster is seen on a
nearby tree put up by the Chichane industries.
Instead of driving to the desert party,
Lukas drives in the opposite direction, which
leads to Brian’s major crush Lisa's home.
Lukas reveals that he has invited her to the
party without telling Brian. Brian freaks out
and tells him to stop but Lukas tells him that
one day or another he will have to man up and
express his feelings to her. Lisa goes to the same
university as Brian and Lukas. She is not only
beautiful and cool, she is smart like Brian.
After picking up Lisa, they head to the party
geeking out over the Eradicator franchise.
Halfway to the party, the Guarisco brothers
show up on their bikes. They flaunt their bike
stunts, forcing Lukas to prove that he is no less.
Lukas asks Brain to take over the steering wheel
and jumps from the truck with his bike to show Tim
and Craig Guarisco who the real boss is.
The two brothers don’t see eye to eye with
Lukas and have a war of words with each other
after reaching the party. Brain defuses the
situation and asks everyone to enjoy the party.
At the party, Lukas again encourages Brian to talk
to Lisa but Brian feels he doesn’t have a cool
personality and can’t do daredevil stunts like
Lukas. Lukas asks him to stop his pity party
and suggests him to confidently ask her out
cause that’s what girls like. However,
before Brian could even approach her,
Craig and Tim start hitting on her and Brian
again loses hope. As Lukas gets busy on stage,
thanking everyone for coming to his
party, Brian wanders into the desert.
While acknowledging Brian‘s major contribution in
his victory, Lukas notices that Brian is missing
from the crowd and goes looking for him. He finds
him on the edge of the chasm . They both notice
Jorge’s abandoned truck on the other side of the
chasm and the tunnel down below. Lukas forces
Brain to come along with him to check out the
tunnel. They come across the Chichane Industries
facility, which Brain says is one of the biggest
military contractors in the US. Afraid of getting
shot, Brian advises against entering the private
property but Lukas doesn’t heed his advice.
As they inspect the elaborate military facility,
Lisa comes looking for them by the chasm. Inside
the desolate facility, Brain and Lukas come across
a mess hall and kitchen with a refrigerator that
is still cold and operating. They decide to go
further into the facility and find a room labelled
"Batch 9". Inside, they find gooey liquids and
webs. They suddenly hear strange sounds coming
outside. Frightened, Lukas finally decides
to get the hell out of the facility. However,
as they head for the exit, they come across a
giant ant in the mess hall and quickly hide in
the kitchen. Lukas gets a call from Lisa and he
tells her that they are stuck in the facility with
a giant ant. He manages to ask her to come down to
the tunnel and help them before his phone dies.
With no choice than to fight, they arm
themselves with, wait for it, a takoyaki
pan and grill spatula. The ant eventually finds
them in the kitchen and their weapons prove to
be useless. The two buddies run to the mess but
the ant jumps over them and blocks their exit. It
corners Lukas but Brain bravely saves his friend
by luring the ant towards himself. He then slides
towards the exit but the ant again jumps over him
and blocks him from running away. Brian hits the
button next to the exit and the gate begins to
close. However, the ant grabs him and tries to
pull him towards itself. Brian freaks out and
asks for Lukas's help. Lukas rushes towards his
friend and tries to pull him out but the ant
starts pulling both of them towards itself.
The two guys almost resign but suddenly Lisa
appears on the other side and starts hammering
the ant, eventually killing the monster.
Lukas celebrates the victory while Lisa
speculates that more such ants could attack
them as wounded ants emit alarm pheromones
that send nearby ants into an attack frenzy
and attract more ants from farther away.
Lisa’s prophecy quickly comes true
and more ants arrive from outside,
forcing them to go deeper into the facility and
hide. They realise that they are in some sort
of control room. Suddenly, a video starts to play
on one of the computers and a man named Dr. John
Renard, head of the US military project “Them”. He
reveals in 1951 a meteor brought alien creatures
on earth. The US contained the creatures and
kept them for testing and experimentation.
Using a piece of the original alien DNA,
scientists spliced their DNA from fire ants
and spiders to create the giant creatures
for military research purposes but one day,
due to a security breach, the batch 9 broke free
and killed all private security forces. Moreover,
one dozen scientists have gone missing and
are presumed dead. Dr. Renard speculates
that after feeding, the batch 9 will attempt
to make a colony somewhere dark and cool where
the queen ant can lay eggs. He also reveals that
the ants require ethanol to fertilize the eggs.
Lisa suddenly realises that their desert
party has an endless supply of ethanol
aka alcohol and the trio quickly head to the
party to warn others. However, the army of ants
reaches the party before them and launches
an attack, sending everyone into a frenzy.
Tim and Craig quickly hop on
their bikes and proceed to flee
meanwhile others become victims of the ants one
by one. A small group of ants follows the Guarisco
brothers and manage to trip Craig over and
capture him while Tim helplessly drives away.
Brian and his friends finally arrive and
learn that the ants have already wrecked havoc
at the party. They decide to head to the
town but as soon as they get on their trucks,
they come under attack by an ant. They freak
out and get on two bikes and drive away.
They split to trick the ants following them
and Brain heads towards the chasm with Lisa,
planning to jump over the fissure. However, Lisa
tells him that he can’t make it to the other side
and trips the bike over to stop him.
Brian gets upset that she feels he can’t jump over
the chasm while she probably thinks Lukas can.
Lisa corrects him and tells him that Lukas can’t
make it to the other side either. Brian tells her
that Lukas would at least try. Lisa agrees but
tells him that’s why she thinks Luksa is an idiot.
She reminds Brian that just because they are in a
dire situation doesn’t mean he has to do anything
reckless. She tells him that he is smarter than
that and that’s why she likes him. Brian is taken
aback by the confession and gets lost in his
thoughts meanwhile an ant quietly takes Lisa away.
Brian snaps out of his dreams and Lukas arrives.
The two follow the ant to the star caves. Deep
inside the caves, they come across giant glowing
ant eggs. They also find Lisa and their friends
from the party wrapped alive inside silk cocoons.
Suddenly, an ant shows up but Dr. Renard
appears from behind and kills the ant.
The scientist tells them that they must leave
immediately before the other ants return. Brian
refuses to leave without Lisa but Dr. Renard
tells him that they can’t open the cocoon without
special tools. Lukas tells his friend that if
they all die, no one will be able to save Lisa
and Brian finally agrees to leave but not before
promising Lisa that he will return to get her.
As they head towards the facility to fetch tools
required to rescue Lisa and others on foot,
Dr. Renard warns them that automated sentry
guns protecting the facility must have been
activated after the release of his SOS video. He
also shows them a map containing the locations of
the sentry guns around the facility. He further
reveals that the ants will start looking for
other sources of prey i.e., the nearest town
which leaves the trio with 30 minutes to act.
Halfway to the facility, an ant appears from
behind and impales the scientist. Horrified, Brian
and Lukas run away and enter the facility from
the back to avoid getting shelled by machine guns.
Passing through the hallway, they come across
a giant gate inside a chamber but fail to open
it. Dejected, they proceed to return but only to
find an ant feeding on a corpse in the hallway,
forcing them back into the chamber. Lukas
suggests calling the authorities but Brain
fears that the government could nuke the town
to stop the scourge. With no other choice left,
they decide to take on the ant. Lukas first
decides to drink a beer in case he dies
and grabs a beer can from the refrigerator in the
adjoining room but to their astonishment, it opens
the gate. Inside, they find a smart rifle, plasma
bolt cutter and combat suits. Fully equipped,
they neutralize the ant outside and head to
the star caves in bikes parked outside.
Brian quieltey frees Lisa and then lures the
ants outside the cave to give Lukas freedom
to free other people and destroy the ant
eggs. Brian leads the ants to the facility
setting them up to get shelled by the automatic
machine guns. The plan succeeds and they celebrate
but only to realise that the queen ant is
still alive and watching over them from above.
Fearing for their lives, they drive towards
the chasm, followed closely behind by the ant.
Brian initially hesitates from jumping over the
fissure but Lisa gives him some “encouragement”
and they successfully make it to the other
side. The two then proceed to flee in Jorge’s
abandoned pick up truck but the queen ant starts
pulling them towards herself with silk threads.
Lisa opens fire on the ant but the
ant manages to take down their truck
along with itself. The two jump out of
the truck and barely make it out alive.
Meanwhile, after sending everyone
to safety, Lukas proceeds to set
the nest on fire but an egg hatches and
the baby ant attacks Lukas, accidentally
setting the nest on fire in the process.
Brian and Lisa arrive outside the cave to learn
that Lukas is still inside. Brian proceeds
to head in but Tim stops him, telling him
that Lukas saved their lives and he wouldn’t
want his best friend endangering his life.
Craig arrives on his bike and learns that Lukas
saved everyone’s life but is still stuck inside.
Craig immediately starts his bike and heads into
the cave as Brian and others nervously wait.
The cave eventually explodes and out
comes Craig with Lukas, safe and sound.
Everyone erupts into cheers and hugs each other
forgetting whatever animosity they may have had.
The group returns to their party
and the Eradicator finally arrives.
Brian is excited to see his idol and offers him
his last beer. However, a giant ant appears from
behind and snatches the beer, scaring the crap out
of the “hero”. However, Brian, Lukas and Lisa do
not cower down and point guns at the creature.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thanks for watching.